Hello Freak bitches.
Shocking.
There's two shocking things that these pills have done for me is for you to
remember one,
remembering dreams and to being lucid in the middle of a dream.
I stayed in a dream.
I was in a dream and I stayed in the dream.
I said,
oh well this is just a fucking dream.
And I just,
I didn't even go lucid.
Like I didn't try to control it or move around.
I just let the dream play out.
But I realized it was a dream and I still didn't wake up.
I have,
that's a rare thing for me just for that chef dreams.
I have dreams.
I have been fucking crazy dreams,
but I am totally lucid inside my dreams.
Dreams that I'm reading something and I'll go,
I'll be,
I'll go,
wow,
that's so funny that I'm reading something because nothing's there in the dream.
I'll pick this.
Nothing's there in my minds making up these words,
but I'm still reading them.
That's so interesting.
I had a dream one time that me and Elvis walked into his hotel room and there
were four dudes,
but fucking right.
And I just hear me where they were.
That might be one of the best sentences ever created.
I had a dream that I was with Elvis and we walked into his dressing room.
There was four dudes,
but fucking dot,
dot,
dot.
Now hear me out it weird or they're throwing up in Burger King cups should just
fucking each other and then I,
where do you,
when I say this,
I fucking just shut the door and I looked at Elvis.
I go,
what the fuck's going on in your room?
He said to me,
what's your Dream Baby Shit?
I wake up,
I wake up.
I'm like,
wake up.
Check my Dick and make sure it's,
I'm bored.
I'm like,
well you don't really flipped me out.
You don't really put me out.
Not that.
Not that the guys were both fucking right.
They didn't ask.
No.
It was the product placement like what the fuck did Burger King do to get it?
When did they figured it out and you just don't know that they are just waiting
Jack to advertising into your Dream Burger King in the future.
Right now.
It's like I got her Chrysler stream about the Elvis and the buck fucking high,
Huh?
No,
no,
no.
But what is,
there is a possibility that someone could insert a product into a dream,
right?
They could give you a cheeseburger and in that cheeseburger with some
experimental thing that would make you think about burger king in a dream and
see a burger and a dream,
you can do it.
You can do it.
I fucking girl from behind.
It's going Geico and shit.
Yes.
Work in the future.
But that doesn't make any sense cause you have the Pronto duck noises.
It's Geico to eat something,
to have this happen to you.
We're still,
we're still missing the whole point.
We're stumbling on something very brilliant right now.
Yeah.